for those who like to hit the trails  there's a new pathway that's just  waiting to be explored the Western  Beltway Trail now extends past  Centennial Parkway turning into the  northern Beltway Trail this is a three  mile essentially an extension now and it  passes Hualapai it passes Fort Apache  and even more and then it ends over at  Grand Montecito the crossing at  hualapaiway is close to a shopping  center maybe need a bit of a pit stop a  spokesperson for North Las Vegas admits  they're aware of safety concerns as  cyclists are crossing Durango so a  traffic light is already in place but  City Engineers are still looking into